[Musique]
cher journal je me demande si on voit
tous les mêmes couleurs enfin si on les
voit tous de la même manière
c'est ce que je vois et bleu et qu'on
m'a dit que cette couleur s'appelle du
bleu qu'est ce qui prouve que stéphanie
ne voit par en bleu ce que moi j'appelle
du jaune si l on lui a appris que cette
couleur s'appelle bleus est ce que mon
bleu peut être le jaune de quelqu'un
d'autre
si je trouve que le rouge et le rose ne
vont pas ensemble fait que steve
président herman rouge comme son jaune
et monrose comme son bleu sachant que je
trouve que le jaune et le bleu se marie
bien et c'est pour ça que je trouve
qu'elle a des goûts de merde
est ce pour ça qu'on n'arrive plus à se
comprendre depuis qu'elle a décidé de
repeindre notre chambre en vert prairie
je me demande vraiment si c'est bien la
femme de ma vie je voudrais tellement
qu'elle me dise que son verre et mont
bleu outremer
j'accepterai alors beaucoup plus
facilement de dormir dans cette pièce
qui ressemble à une salle d'attentes de
pédiatres de province j'ai envie d'y
croire
jean bie alors oui bonjour monsieur et
ses dangers je sais pas parce que je
crois qu on a échangé nos carnets le
carnet oui non avec se trouve que j'ai
le vôtre du queens que vous avez incarné
avec des pages et des trucs et puis ça
oui j'étais en train de s qui
éventuellement je pourrais passer chez
vous le faire chez vous devant chez vous
donne mon adresse oui par textos mais ok
non non ne vous inquiétez pas non non je
ferme tout est ok merci beaucoup
eh ben
envoyons sage alors merci à j 3 h 34
pourquoi pas la 34 elle est très bien la
34e la wii alors oui merde
ah ouais d'accord
[Musique]
[Rires]